sur les 300 places qu'on avait réservé
vous êtes au moins 250 275 a vu de nez
donc merci d'avoir bravé nos deux
malédiction de la journée la tempête de
neige le vendredi 13 deux choses qui
jouaient contre nous on est content de
vous avoir avec nous
auditeur à la maison au travail ou sur
la route je ne vous oublie pas je suis
tout aussi heureux de vous savoir à
l'écoute d'ailleurs pour ceux qui ont
accès à un ordinateur si vous voulez
nous voir la binette l'émission est
également web diffusée sur les sites de
Radio-Canada.ca sur la page Youtube de
Radio-Canada et sur la page Facebook de
Radio-Canada information si vous avez
des questions pour nos correspondants
vous pouvez écrire à la page Facebook de
Radio-Canada information dans la section
commentaire ou alors directement
l'adresse courriel de midi info midi
info en un
mot@radio-canada.ca on va également
prendre des questions du public de la
salle pendant l'émission la journaliste
internationale Annick Béraud membre de
l'équipe de midi info qui est maintenant
envoyé spécial a déjà été en poste à
Washington Paris Jérusalem est avec nous
elle est dans la salle pour cueillir vos
questions Annick bonjour bonjour Alex
bonjour tout le monde merci beaucoup
d'être là c'est très apprécié d'ailleurs
pour ceux qui se posent la question on a
reçu des courriels qui se demandaient
quelle est la différence entre les
correspondants à l'étranger les envoyer
spéciaux pourquoi l'émission vous n'avez
pas par exemple Jean-Michel Leprince
Annick Béraud Jean-François Bélanger
Manon globenski entre autres sur
l'émission parce que sont des envoyés
spéciaux qui se déplacent lorsque des
événements à découvrir alors que nos
correspondants à l'étranger qui sont
avec moi ben sont en poste de manière
permanente dans un autre pays c'est la
petite nuance entre les deux sans plus
tarder je voulais présente ceux qui sont
avec moi ici au studio C de Radio-Canada
nous correspondant à l'étranger
exceptionnellement réuni tous à Montréal
Philippe Leblanc correspondant en Asie
basée à Taipei à Taïwan bonjour bonjour
Raphaël Bouvier auclac correspondant en
Europe qui est basé à Paris bonjour
Raphaël très heureux d'être ici ben
merci beaucoup Marie-Eve Bédard
correspondante en Europe également basée
à Paris bonjour Alex bonjour à tous
Tamara Alteresco correspondante
internationale qui était basée en Russie
jusqu'en mars dernier vous savez ce qui
s'est produit avec le bureau de
Radio-Canada à Moscou qui suit
particulièrement ces jours-ci l'Europe
de l'Est les anciens satellites
soviétiques Tamara bonjour Merci
correspondante à Washington bonjour Alex
et frédéric Arnould le dernier mais dans
le moindre correspondant également au
Washington bonjour Frédéric bonjour
merci de nous accueillir
on parlera évidemment de votre métier de
vos façons de travailler de la guerre en
Ukraine qui vous a tout s'occuper
beaucoup cette année d'autres sujets
aussi que vous avez dû couvrir tous ces
gens dont les libertés ont été brimées
je pense aux femmes aux réfugiés les
peuples aussi qui à qui on impose la
censure les événements un peu partout
dans le monde la Chine l'Iran l'Europe
bref vous avez c'est pas mal occupé dans
les derniers mois et cette pour cette
première partie d'émission on souhaite
d'abord aborder les coulisses de votre
métier je vais vous adresser d'abord la
première question parce que c'est la
prérogative de l'animateur de pouvoir en
profiter question qui s'adresse à tous
Peut-être rapidement tour de micro le
plus grand défi auquel vous êtes
confronté présentement dans l'exercice
de votre métier de correspondant à
l'étranger de commencer par Philippe bon
on a tous des enjeux différents moi je
vais particulièrement cibler celui du
fait que je suis seul à taper je suis
caméraman je suis je suis monteur je
suis journaliste donc
qui diffèrent les uns des autres il faut
être au courant d'un peu tout ce qui se
passe parce qu'on peut être appelé à
débarquer dans un pays pour couvrir une
élection trois jours plus tard on va
aller à l'autre bout du continent où le
système politique est complètement
différent j'ai pas d'études
d'universitaire poussée dans chacun de
ces régimes là on essaie de lire mais on
a toujours des petites surprises sur le
terrain c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a des
équipes des collègues pour nous appuyer
mais ça c'est un des défis au quotidien
pour le poste en Europe particulière
j'ai un peu un défi qui est celui de
Raphaël parce qu'on couvre le même
continent donc il faut constamment se
tenir informé de ce qui se passe mais
j'ai aussi un pied qui reste assez ancré
au Moyen-Orient qui est une région que
j'ai découvert pendant plusieurs années
auparavant donc ça élargit d'autant le
territoire et je pense que le plus grand
défi c'est de prioriser parfois
peut-être les propositions de couverture
les déplacements qu'on fait et d'arriver
à trouver un certain équilibre entre
tout ce qui se passe sur la planète
parce qu'on peut pas être partout tout
le temps alors c'est peut-être choisir
le bon endroit au bon moment on y arrive
pas toujours mais c'est c'est ce qui me
préoccupe le plus je veux dire Tamara
été expulsé de Russie et d'avoir à
couvrir à couvrir la réussite à essayer
à continuer de d'alimenter mes analyses
sur le peuple russe sans pouvoir y
mettre les pieds c'est vrai qu'on a
encore des contacts en Russie on en a
beaucoup et contrairement à ce que les
gens pensent même avec le gouvernement
on maintient ce lien-là parce qu'on
espère pouvoir y retourner mais même
dans les discussions personnelles que ça
soit avec des amis ou des contacts que
j'ai là-bas il y a un malaise qui vient
de la peur des gens de parler
ouvertement donc les conversations sont
très banales comment ça va ça va bien
trois petits points il y a plein de
sous-entendus de non-dits et pour moi
qui veut continuer à essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe en Russie par
rapport aux conflits en Ukraine mais
aussi avec les relations avec la Chine
avec tout ce que la Russie représente
sur le plan géopolitique c'est
extrêmement difficile en ce moment
[Musique]
je dirais que en un mot je pense que le
plus grand défi je pense pour nous tous
d'ailleurs c'est vraiment
c'est le mot choisir en fait choisir les
sujets il y a tellement de sujets aux
États-Unis c'est 50 États à couvrir
c'est plusieurs enjeux on a l'impression
de couvrir 50 pays en fait alors
pourquoi on irait parce qu'on devrait
plus couvrir les questions sur
l'avortement sur la démocratie sur
toutes les tueries choisir pourquoi on
couvre-t-elle fusillade plutôt qu'une
autre donc c'est vraiment choisir le bon
sujet qui va aussi intéresser notre
notre public je pense que ça c'est un de
mes plus grands défis Frédéric pas mieux
non mais c'est vrai que c'est un peu la
prévisibilité en fait parce que on le
voit le théâtre politique ces espèces de
joute entre les républicains et
démocrates ça très mal commencé
d'ailleurs cette année c'est très
prometteur à suivre mais justement ça il
faut sortir aussi de cette bulle
politique et d'aller voir mais toujours
sur le terrain alors en essayant on est
toujours pris entre entre ces deux feux
là de l'actualité au quotidien mais
aussi aller voir et comprendre mieux ces
sociétés américaines qui est quand même
très complexe avec des bonus avec des
malus mais une société qui reste
évidemment fascinante à couvrir et dont
on apprend aussi chaque jour même si on
est en pause depuis maintenant un an et
demi on va aller la première question du
public du côté de Annick Béraud Annick
je te cède la parole oui et moi je me
dirige vers Pierrette Savard bonjour
merci d'être là et vous avez une
question je vous cède le micro pour la
poser à nos correspondants d'accord moi
j'aimerais savoir il y a plusieurs
correspondants de plusieurs pays qui
couvrent les mêmes choses que vous
est-ce que vous avez une bonne
collaboration entre vous les corresponds
les correspondants étrangers sur le
terrain je vais adresser la question à
Marie-Ève parce que vous avez obtenu une
entrevue avec le président crânien
voilàki qui a été je pense un travail
d'équipe entre plusieurs réseaux de
médias expliquez-nous ça un peu comment
ça fonctionne
en fait là c'était pas avec des
correspondantes d'autres pays c'était
des correspondants de concurrents
Canadiens bon CBC c'est la chaîne
anglophone c'est nos petits frères nos
grands frères mais si tu vis aussi et
c'est la façon qu'on a trouvé
collectivement la suggestions de notre
collègue de City d'ailleurs par Walkman
de miser sur une demande d'entrevue
commune parce que depuis le début du
conflit on était tous demanda de cette
entrevue avec le président et on
arrivait jamais à nous caler dans
lagenda et à partir du moment où on leur
proposait de travailler ensemble et de
faire une entrevue commune ça a débloqué
toutes les portes et là soudainement on
a trouvé beaucoup plus de temps parce
que du côté de la présidence ce qu'on
nous disait aussi après quand on y est
arrivé c'est qu'on avait du mal à
choisir on ne voulait pas on ne pouvait
pas dire oui à tout le monde parce que
le Canada est déjà un pays allié amis à
qui on a très peu de messages à envoyer
parce que c'est beaucoup ça aussi la
communication des dirigeants c'est pour
s'adresser aux populations des pays qui
sont présentés par les médias à leur
dirigeants pour obtenir de l'Inde et
donc d'avoir offert de travailler
communément ça nous a permis de
rencontrer le président d'obtenir cette
entrevue mais plus largement
peut-être plus dans les zones hostiles
dans les zones de conflits c'est un
assez petit milieu c'est des gens croise
dans mon cas depuis 20 ans je revois
toujours les mêmes visages c'est des
collègues qu'on finit par bien
comprendre et il y a toujours un enjeu
sécuritaire pour tout le monde et sur
ces questions là on collabore beaucoup
on partage de l'information même si on
reste quand même un peu compétiteur sur
les sujets sur des exclusivités quand il
s'agit de partager de l'information qui
peut être utile à tout le monde oui ça
on se crie souvent des groupes des chats
où on va se partager de l'information on
s'échange aussi des ressources sur place
et ça nous aide tout le monde et ça
n'enlève rien à qui que ce soit et moi
je dirais que ça va même plus loin parce
que ce partage là cette collaboration là
ça a été une des raisons pour lesquelles
ça a été si facile d'ouvrir le bureau à
Taipei on était plusieurs qui qui ont dû
s'établir là parce qu'on pouvait pas
aller en Chine des gens qui sont partis
dans Hong Kong c'est grâce à l'aide des
collègues du Washington pose du New-York
Times qui ont partagé des informations
tu pensais à regarder si tu contactais
telle personne qu'on réussit à partager
l'information je ne sens pas en ce
moment d'esprit de compétition sur le
sur le terrain quand vous débarquez dans
un pays comme l'Ukraine il y a
évidemment des journalistes Ukrainiens
qui sont là qui couvrent leur propre
conflits comme Frédéric je vous en avez
rencontré quand vous êtes allés en
Ukraine est-ce qu'il vous aide à
comprendre leur pays est-ce qu'il vous
voit comme une bonne menace dans le sens
où mais en disant bon là il débarque
parce qu'il se passe quelque chose mais
nous on n'aura pas la tension comment ça
se passe avec les journalistes locaux
mais c'est sûr je vais écrire un papier
là-dessus j'avais rencontré deux
journalistes de Kevin dependence qui
sont qui sont très excessivement suivis
c'est devenu un peu la source
d'information pour l'extérieur de
l'Ukraine et donc ils ont un vraiment
une capacité d'atteindre un auditoire
assez incroyable et donc je leur posais
justement la question à savoir mais
comment tu fais pour couvrir un conflit
qui se passe dans ton propre pays alors
évidemment déchirant parce que on ne
peut pas passer sous silence un billet
je pense qui est naturel c'est-à-dire
ils ont des préjugés contre contre les
Russes et donc ça se reflète forcément
dans la dans leur couverture et donc je
vais dire on serait dans la même
situation par exemple si les Américains
décidaient d'envahir le Canada bon
rarement mais Tamara il y a comme une
petite inclinaison vous posez la
question mais on n'a pas été expulsé
parce qu'on était critique du régime
puis
on n'est pas là et je pense que ça a été
la même le même dilemme pour mais c'est
pas un dilemme il a même difficulté
quand on couvre dans l'autre chambre des
gens qui sont très polarisants dans le
cas de la Russie
[Musique]
les gens sont toujours étonnés quand ça
aussi quand je leur dis faire mon
travail assez librement beaucoup plus
que les Russes le son et avec moins
d'enjeux sécuritaire souvent les gens
ils se tapaient pas peur de travailler
en Russie les pacs qu'on a publiécru
c'est presque nul alors que les médias
locaux et là il y en a plus un demi-1
indépendants mais ceux qui avaient le
courage de le faire depuis les 20
dernières années sont ceux qui sont en
danger et ceux dont les libertés sont
brimées et maintenant n'en existantes je
vais profiter de la présence d'Annick
Béraud ma collègue que le chat voilà en
face de moi Annick était la dernière
correspondante de Radio-Canada Pékin
donc lorsque la covid de frappée le
bureau comme ça a été fermé Philippe
nous a expliqué qu'on a effectivement
maintenant un bureau à Taipei à Taïwan
mais comment c'était couvrir le régime
chinois lorsque vous étiez là-bas
et bien il faut faire preuve de
créativité là pour exposer les faits là
qui vont souvent à l'encontre de
discours officiel donc ça veut dire
aller sur le terrain parler aux gens qui
subissent les conséquences des décisions
qui ont été prises par le régime ça veut
dire aussi pas parler seulement aux
dissidents mais aux opposants aussi
autant que faire ce peu aux experts pour
essayer de mettre ça en contexte ça
devenait de plus en plus difficile avec
en 2019 quand on a rencontré par exemple
les gens Hong Kong lors des
manifestations bien l'année suivante en
2020 avec la loi sur la sécurité
nationale et bien de critiquer le régime
les gens pouvaient se faire poursuivre
pour sédition pour trahison au début de
la covid aussi quand les images étaient
à l'encontre de discours officiels comme
je disais qu'on ça pouvait fuiter malgré
la censure on voyait des sacs mortuaires
on voyait les hôpitaux débordés d'aller
parler aux gens et s'exposaient au
danger de nous parler et on sentait
aussi que ça devenait difficile de
parler même à des experts à l'approche
de d'anniversaire sensibles pour le
régime je pense
au troisième anniversaire du massacre de
la donc il y avait des défis des
obstacles physiques on en parle on a
tous on a tous vu ça sur le terrain et
aussi le danger est un arabe en faisait
mention c'est pour nous mais aussi pour
les gens qui acceptent de nous parler
les gens qui acceptent de nous guider
les fixeurs et donc ils prennent
beaucoup de risques parce que nous on
part on part avec notre matériel et on
fait en sorte si une préoccupation qu'on
a tous je crois de pas les mettre en
danger non plus qu'on va les voir parce
que on le sait quand on rentre quelque
part tout le monde est en Chine c'est
assez particulier tout le monde sait que
un média étranger est venu voir ou au
moins un étranger parce qu'elle a
surveillance électronique mais aussi les
gens au bas des immeubles qui
surveillent les allées et Venus et donc
j'ai un immense respect je pense qu'on
je je je crois que si partager le
immense respect pour ceux qui nous
parlent ceux qui nous aident et une
immense gratitude aussi
ma question par courriel de Gilles
Jodoin qui se demande comment les
correspondants à l'étranger organise
leur vie familiale surtout s'ils ont des
enfants Raphaël vous avez eu un enfant
cette année bravo félicitations un
nouveau papa comment on s'organise
lorsqu'on doit être des pêcheurs tout le
monde mais qu'on a des enfants mais il
faut faire preuve de flexibilité et il
faut tenter d'organiser la vie non
seulement autour du travail mais aussi
autour de la vie familiale parce que on
les collègues le souligne aussi c'est
les membres de notre famille qui
viennent avec nous font des sacrifices
pour vivre cette expérience qui est
extraordinaire on a la chance d'être
basé dans un autre pays de vivre
l'expérience et de la vivre en famille
mais ça implique aussi toutes sortes de
sacrifices pour les gens qui nous
accompagnent et donc il faut nous aussi
être présent dans mon cas si par exemple
partir pour des moins longues périodes
de temps pour pouvoir être à la maison
pour pouvoir passer du temps
avec Auguste c'est son prénom
et donc des déploiements de quoi trois
quatre jours c'est comme ça qu'on tente
de s'organiser puis c'est intéressant
aussi et ça je l'ai souligné à
l'émission télé hier mais c'est
intéressant aussi d'avoir une famille et
en tout cas de créer une famille à
l'étranger aussi parce que ça nous donne
accès au système de santé par exemple au
système des garderies dans les pays où
on se trouve puis ça parfois ça nous
permet de voir comment les gens dans le
pays où on est basé vivent le quotidien
puis ça enrichit également notre
expérience de correspondant d'avoir ce
contact au quotidien avec les réalités
de la vie dans l'endroit dans lequel on
y va Frédéric vous avez couvert au Texas
la tuerie d'où le valdé plusieurs jeunes
enfants ont été tués vous avez vous-même
des jeunes enfants est-ce que ça influe
sur la manière dont vous couvrir les
événements c'est sûr qu'on peut pas
faire abstraction de ça parce qu'en plus
dans le cas de ovale des il y avait des
enfants 19 enfants qui ont été abattus à
beau portant avec un fusil militaire qui
permet de faire éclater une tête dans
des conflits gaz je veux dire c'est un
concevable et ces enfants-là avaient à
peu près le même âge que les miens donc
c'est sûr que encore une fois c'est
c'est l'horreur encore une fois c'est la
violence de la société américaine et
cette accessibilité totale à des armes
qui ne pourquoi a-t-on besoin d'une arme
de niveau militaire comme ça c'est pas
pour aller faire la chasse c'est pas
vrai alors il y en a qui qui en achètent
des dizaines qui les collectionnent et à
un moment il y a quelque chose qui se
passe dans son esprit il va les utiliser
tout ça donc c'est sûr que quand je vois
ça et quand je vois le couvrir il faut
que j'explique à mes enfants parce que
bon je voyage quand même assez souvent
aux États-Unis en général quand je me
déplace c'est parce que ça va pas bien
donc il faut que je leur explique un peu
mon baie rassurez-vous je vais être je
vais être correct mais c'est sûr qu'il
faut que je leur explique ben là il y a
quelqu'un qui est entré dans une classe
une école comme la tienne ils ont tiré
et puis voilà il y a des victimes alors
c'est ça fait partie de notre quotidien
je veux dire je veux dire Azeb aussi à
son fils à l'école américaine il y a des
des simulations de confinement de log
down bon ben des enfants doivent savoir
exactement quoi faire quand il y a une
situation d'homme armée qui entre dans
l'école alors c'est sûr que ça c'est un
impact sur nous aussi au niveau mental
parce que ça pourrait très bien nous
arriver à nos enfants de ce genre de
situation là ce serait évidemment
horrible qu'on soit en plus amené à
couvrir ça sans le savoir d'abord au
début mais c'est sûr que ça fait partie
du quotidien et bon ben après ça c'est
aux Américains se prendre en main et
passer à autre chose que des des prières
et des pensées et rien faire au niveau
au niveau politique et continuer de
donner l'accès de plus en plus à ces
armes là c'est ça qu'il faut c'est qu'on
se dit mais ils vont réagir à un moment
donné c'est pas possible on peut pas
tuer comme ça des enfants et bien pas du
tout en général il y a d'autres
règlements législatives dans des états
évidemment qui sont plus conservateurs
qui disent ben non non justement la
solution à tout ça c'est de s'armer
davantage et de faciliter que les gens
puissent se promener avec leur arme bien
en évidence quand ils vont au
supermarché du coin donc nous on est là
dedans en fait c'est une guerre une
guerre sans fin vous savez quand on
couvre des conflits souvent il y a un si
c'est le feu enfin on espère sauf qu'aux
États-Unis même au niveau du Congrès il
s'entendent pas pour interdire les
fusils d'infos ils s'entendent même pas
pour interdire de vendre une arme à
quelqu'un qui a des antécédents
judiciaires ou psychiatriques il y a un
débat là-dessus alors que ça pour pour
nous c'est très normal donc ça fait
partie d'une réalité qu'on non seulement
quand on couvre ses fusillades là mais
une réalité quotidienne vous allez faire
vos épiceries vous allez je sais pas où
donc Provigo vous avez un gardien de
sécurité armé jusqu'aux dents donc c'est
toujours dans votre esprit en fait que
ça peut arriver à n'importe quel moment
n'importe où même à Washington la
capitale américaine il y a des il y a
des tiers il y a des fusillades il y a
des règlements de compte je veux dire
juste cette année il y a eu quoi plus de
600 tirés aux États-Unis on parle de
40000 morts par année par armes à feu
bon la moitié c'est ce sont des suicides
mais c'est quand même un problème qui ne
se règle pas en fait qui est toujours là
et qui va demeurer comme Frédéric le dit
c'est ça protégez-vous ayez des armes et
puis il y a des fusillades plus les gens
ça donc c'est c'est un effet dominant
Marcel Le Boeuf nous écrit par courriel
veut savoir de quoi me composer votre
valise ou votre sac à dos si vous devez
quitter précipitamment votre lieu de
résidence moi j'ai entendu dire que les
correspondent avaient toujours un petit
sac à dos près je sais pas si vous avez
différents passeport de différentes
nationalités comme dans les films mais
pas des agents secrets non pas les
agents secrets non il y a pas de crayon
avec des maisons micro enregistreurs
cachés Marie-Ève qu'est-ce que vous avez
dans votre sac à dos prêt à partir très
peu de choses en fait oui vous voyagez
[Musique]
probablement un ensemble de vêtements
pour me changer mais c'est tout mais
sinon je ne prépare pas beaucoup mes
valises à l'avance mais ça c'est un
talent je pense qu'il se développe avec
le temps moi je peux faire une valise
pour un mois en 3 minutes ah oui elle
est prête tout est bouclé et je pars je
vais souvent avec des choses qui sont
confortables familières et puis j'en
mets un peu plus que moins pour
m'assurer que je ne manque de rien mais
ça me prend vraiment pas beaucoup de
temps pour pouvoir me passeport par
contre lui je l'ai toujours dans les
poches est-ce que quelqu'un qui est plus
organisé que Marielle ici autour de
donner des formations sur comment faire
rentrer un mois de vêtements dans une
période
mais on ne l'habitude on sait aussi le
confort Parce qu'on fait de la télé
alors il faut moi il y a toujours un
fond de teint à Mascara un élastique
pour un chignon parce que à défaut de
pouvoir me mais c'est vrai que on
développe moi j'ai jamais un sac prêt
mais j'ai toujours mon passeport
dans mon sac à main on retourne question
du public canicaire
vous lever parce que on veut vous
entendre mais aussi vous voir ici donc
et je vous laisse poser votre question
aux correspondants allez-y oui bonjour
merci pour votre travail les questions
concernent un peu le logistique puis le
choix de sujet vous avez parlé au début
de comment un sujet à choisir votre
influence dans le choix du sujet et
après ça la logistique qui suit incluant
une fixure pour les pays on a besoin
d'être fixés mais à la banque avec d'un
autre Trump peut-être on a besoin d'une
fiction aussi mais c'est justement ceci
décide la priorité à travers vote vos
yeux sur le territoire Philippe comment
on fait ses choix comment ça fonctionne
c'est un peu le même défi que Marie-Ève
et Raphaël ont c'est-à-dire que moi
c'est une région énorme l'Asie donc il y
a des choix à faire des priorités des
priorités qu'on doit établir avec la
direction de Radio-Canada moi je vais
suggérer des idées et d'ici on a aussi
une autre vision de ma réalité sur le
terrain donc pouvoir qu'est-ce qui nous
nous intéresse et c'est là qu'on fait
l'évaluation est-ce que ça c'est un vrai
sujet ou ce que ça de l'est pas mais moi
personnellement j'écoute énormément la
fixeuse avec laquelle je travaille de
façon permanente qui fait la recherche
qui parle le mandarin qui habite là
depuis longtemps elle va être capable de
me suggérer des sujets
auxquels on n'aurait pas pensé
nécessairement ici et une fois qu'on
décide des sujets que ce soit sur place
ou ailleurs il y a tout le volet
préparation vous l'avez dit il y a pas
de réseau international ou un baptême
international où on va appeler un fixeur
dans tel pays je vais aller aux
Philippines par exemple
c'est du bouche à oreille c'est un
fixeur qui va en connaître un autre ou
c'est un collègue qui est déjà allé on
va essayer de se passer facilement et
c'est surtout ça le principal défi je
pense quand on se promène de payer en
pays ou qu'on découvre un nouveau pays
c'est comment trouver la bonne personne
là-bas qui va être
Excell pour la recherche pour nous
amener à rencontrer les gens qui vont
être un peu une extension de nos yeux de
nos oreilles sur place d'ailleurs on a
des on a des questions Patricia Hébert
de chibougamour Claude Gauvin aussi qui
se demande à quoi ressemble les équipes
des correspondants à l'étranger on en a
certains ici qui sont dans la salle
Sergio cameraman de monteur à Paris
Gabriel de jasez aussi qui est
journaliste recherchait à Paris quelque
part ici Sylvain qui est cameraman à
Washington on est on les salue est-ce
que c'est des grosses équipes
qui nous gère parce que c'est de la
gestion au quotidien
on lui parle avec jour nos problèmes nos
doléances nos bonheurs nos ou nos bas il
fait un travail assez intense assez
exigeant qui est tout aussi important
dans le choix des sujets dont on parlait
parce que lui il a une vue peut-être
plus d'ensemble nous on a notre vue plus
régionale il y a des discussions avec
lui qui nous aide beaucoup
plusieurs avez-vous interprété de caméra
entrepreneur de son montant à quoi
ressemble un peu vos équipes autour de
vous
on a une caméraman monter Sylvain
Richard on a Marcel calfa qui notre
réalisateur rechercher ce qui nous
prépare les dossiers et c'est vrai que
le défi c'est le choix des sujets il
faut quand même se rappeler que souvent
nous au Téléjournal par exemple c'est
une heure de nouvelles nationales et
internationale donc il y a très peu de
temps pour diffuser nos sujets donc on
est très souvent la nouvelle vient à
nous quand par exemple la reine est
morte c'est évident qu'on va couvrir ce
sujet là aux Etats-Unis bon quand il y a
eu la fusillade du valdé ou de bofolo
les élections de mi-mandat donc en
général les sujets sont très évidents
dès le départ mais le matin on discute
justement avec Patrick Gauthier qui est
notre affectateur et c'est là qu'on
débat des sujets qu'est-ce qu'on devrait
couvrir aujourd'hui c'est quoi vraiment
la nouvelle de la journée aux États-Unis
et c'est pour ça que je dis que notre
grand défi nous c'est de choisir il y a
des sujets environnementaux qu'on
aimerait faire tous les jours
il y a vraiment une urgence climatique
mais on peut mais donc on choisit en
fait et c'est là qu'on a le débat très
tôt le matin sur ce qui va faire la
nouvelle le soir mais quand on se
compare aux autres réseaux je pense
qu'on en parle ensemble Marie-Ève on est
des petites équipes les réseaux français
américains britanniques je pense à la
BBC le déploie à grande échelle nous
nous on s'en plaint pas ça fait partie
de notre réalité on est content d'être à
l'étranger mais c'est exigeant parce
qu'on est des petites équipes
trop petit pour comprendre que la forme
de l'équipe aussi change selon
l'affectation parce que parfois ça va
être un déploiement qui va être
multiplateforme incluant la télé alors
là on part avec un caméraman parfois
avec un réalisateur mais on a aussi des
affectations qui sont purement pour la
radio mais dans ce cas-là on part seul
avec notre micro ça aussi c'est une
réalité parfois donc pas un modèle
d'équipe et dans le cas de Philippe
c'est un véritable homme un orchestre
merci beaucoup on va s'arrêter ici
puisque les nouvelles vont prendre la
relève pour une dizaine de minutes on se
retrouve vers 12h10 dans la salle vous
pouvez vous égosir les jambes une
dizaine de minutes pas plus on revient
puis on reprend la discussion pour la
dernière heure 2019 merci encore d'être
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rebonjour je vous rappelle que nous
sommes en édition spéciale de midi info
dans le cadre de la Semaine des
correspondances nous sommes devant un
public en direct de l'Atrium de
Radio-Canada à la nouvelle maison à
Montréal l'émission est aussi web
diffusée sur Radio-Canada.ca sur Youtube
et sur la page Facebook de Radio-Canada
info vous pouvez aussi nous écrire
directement sur Facebook dans les
commentaires si vous avez des questions
ou alors à l'adresse courriel de midi
info midi info en un
mot@radio-canada.ca les 6 correspondants
à l'étranger sont toujours avec moi
frédéric Arnould les ébold yurgistes
Amaral teresco marie-evedard Raphaël
Bouvier au clair et Philippe Leblanc on
va parler évidemment de la guerre en
Ukraine qui est un thème qui est revenu
beaucoup dans les questions du public
qui vous a tous occupé d'une manière
d'une autre soit sur le terrain soit sur
le plan diplomatique d'ailleurs malgré
le fait que cette guerre a été
déclenchée un peu par surprise disons-le
comme ça il y avait beaucoup de bruits
de bottes mais on pensait peut-être pas
que Vladimir Poutine irait jusqu'au bout
Tamara et Maria vous étiez sur place de
chaque côté de la frontière Tamara à
Kiev en Russie et marie-evaquiem comment
ce sont déroulés vos premières heures à
venir vous pu dormir beaucoup est-ce que
vous étiez parce que c'était 4 heures du
matin comment ça s'est passé Marie-Ève
tuerie parce que tu es un marin à chaque
fois qu'elle raconte cette histoire
raconte nous on rentrait de l'Est du
pays où la guerre de toute façon était
déjà
comment depuis plusieurs années depuis
2014 on oublie beaucoup cet aspect là
mais il y avait des combats dans le don
de base et on venait de rentrer à Kiev
et on attendait donc de façon plutôt
imminente mais sans vraiment vouloir y
croire que les combats ou que l'invasion
a grande échelle ne débute et moi
j'avais dit on a passé la nuit debout on
a conduit si c'est pour commencer j'ai
besoin de dormir je vais me coucher
réveillez-moi s'il se passe quelque
chose
et moi de l'autre côté en Russie où on
nous avait dit que Vladimir Poutine vers
4h du matin à la faire un discours mais
je suis restée debout et avant 4h du
matin
on était dans la chambre d'hôtel et nos
téléphones en sonné il se laisse pas
s'il y avait une alerte enfermé l'espace
aérien donc j'ai appelé notre fameux
Patrick Gaultier et j'ai dit mais on
réveille Marie-Ève et puis à partir de
ce moment-là je pense que pour raconter
les premières heures on était prête on
était prête on était au bon endroit au
bon moment ça c'est prioritaire pour
pour les journalistes mais je pense que
jusqu'à la toute fin c'est pas qu'on
veut pas y croire c'est qu'on se dit en
2022 au coeur de l'Europe il va avoir
quelque chose qui va faire qu'on va
pouvoir éviter cette guerre à grande
échelle nous du balcon on était dans une
ville près de la frontière on voyait au
loin Mario Paul et dans notre analyse un
peu broche à foin qu'on avait fait en
équipe qu'est-ce qui va arriver dans les
prochaines heures on s'était dit
peut-être qu'ils vont aller jusqu'à
Mario Paul qui fait partie du dôme base
que voulait dire Poutine avait reconnu
comme indépendant donc il y a eu un peu
de stupeur mais on est très vite retombé
sur nos pattes pour pour ne pas après
dormir pendant deux trois jours melon
bas c'est une chose le conflit existait
effectivement depuis plusieurs années
mais là la capitale qui est qui subit
les premiers bombardements ce que vous
vous attendiez à ça Maria pas
complètement non c'est là qu'on a
compris à quel point cette opération-là
avait de l'ampleur et qu'elles étaient
les ambitions véritables de Vladimir
Poutine quand on a entendu les premières
explosions c'était en périphérie de la
capitale à ce moment-là au cœur de la
ville mais quand même
c'est là que ça nous a donné en quelque
sorte toute la mesure de ce que cette
opération-là était pas nécessairement
sur la durée parce qu'au début
souvenez-vous on parlait d'un conflit
qui serait réglé en trois jours que la
Russie débarquerait sur la capitale on
avait proposé à voilà des meilleures
années de ski l'asile l'exil on lui
avait offert de le sortir du pays pour
le sauver le protéger ce qu'il avait
refusé de faire mais je pense que
beaucoup avaient compté sur le fait que
ce serait très rapide sans le pomme
mesurer dès le départ mais c'est évident
que c'est un choc passager mais
d'entendre ces explosions là dans la
capitale ça donne toute la mesure de ce
qui est en train de se dérouler de père
avec discours un discours devait devenir
Poutine qui donnait froid dans le dos
quand même très agressif moi je parle
pas parfaitement le Russe je le
comprends c'est bien sauf que il fallait
l'interprète pour virer un discours
historique je peux pas commencer à
improviser ce que je pense avoir compris
et ça se passait en direct on était en
direct et il prévenait l'Occident que si
l'osait se mêler c'était pas clair à
quel niveau de ce conflit là ils
allaient avoir des conséquences qu'ils
n'ont pas vu de l'histoire donc il y
avait un élément une dimension nucléaire
à la suite des choses qu'on avait jamais
entendu aussi clairement de la bouche de
Vladimir Poutine on l'entend beaucoup en
Russie dans la télévision des tas il y a
beaucoup d'enflure
par rapport à cette menace nu faire avec
des graphiques à imaginer si on lance
une bombe sur Londres Londres disparaît
en 10 minutes donc ça on est habitué
mais de l'entendre de la bouche de
Vladimir Poutine alors que Marie-Eve de
son balcon nous voyait les bombes il y
avait quelque chose de très de très
inquiétant très concret réel on a une
question du public Béraud je vous
regarde voilà allez-y je vous laisse la
parole oui c'est toujours de Sylvain
Tremblay et justement il veut entendre
du concret de votre part une question
sur le terrain alors si vous voulez vous
lever vous aussi pour poser votre
question je vous tends le micro merci en
fait la question ça s'adresse à vous
tous et particulièrement aux gens qui
sont près de la ligne de feu jusqu'à
quel point vous risquez pas un peu vos
vies c'est que du côté sécurité comment
est-ce que vous comment est-ce que vous
agissez où êtes-vous entouré ou encadrer
parce que je fais références un topo que
Marielle fait un moment donné avec le
casque puis le le le le gilet pare-balle
et puis m'em
par contre oui je pense mais il faut il
faut on risque pas notre vie au point où
les gens le croient je pense la plupart
du temps n'est pas constamment sur la
ligne de front d'ailleurs le conflit
ukrainien à part cet exemple là et ça
c'était avant le l'invasion par la
Russie c'était pendant les combats dans
le Danne basse je pense que je sais à
quelle image vous faites référence mais
on n'est pas toujours à courir sous les
bombes à fuir les balles on peut couvrir
le conflit sans s'approcher
nécessairement des lignes de front quoi
que moi je pense qu'on doit aussi aller
voir ce qui se passe du côté des combats
parce que ça permet d'informer aussi
notre compréhension de ce conflit là
voir l'état des troupes comment ça se
déroule la population qui reste aussi
parce qu'il y a toujours des gens de la
population civile qui elle demeure
constamment dans ces zones là il y a une
part de risque
qu'on calcule qu'on mesure et on essaie
de se prémunir donc on a l'équipement de
sécurité on a des conseillers en
sécurité qui nous accompagnent aussi qui
sont pour la plupart d'exilitaires on a
des formations qu'on renouvelle
régulièrement
pour nous enseigner un peu à décoder le
terrain mais aussi en premier soin on
est toujours assez bien équipé on sait
où sont les hôpitaux
et puis c'est pas toujours les
explosions les balles aussi dans des
campagnes de bombardements quand on voit
par exemple la Russie détruire de façon
systématique les infrastructures et
élargir beaucoup le champ de bataille en
quelque sorte parce qu'au départ c'était
plus ciblé autour de la capitale ensuite
on s'est déplacé c'était beaucoup dans
l'Est dans le sud mais maintenant il y a
un facteur très aléatoire c'est à dire
qu'il y a des bombardements qui ciblent
oui les infrastructures mais aussi les
habitations de la population civile donc
ça il faut accepter aussi une part
d'inconnu il y a un risque il est
calculé mesuré mais pas complètement
contrôlé ce sera un peu illusoire de
dire qu'on ne risque rien mais j'ai pas
toujours l'impression d'être en train de
sauver ma peau tous les jours quand je
couvre des conflits
je vous rassure je dors très bien oui et
moi je vais demander tu arrives moi mon
problème c'est que je la difficulté à
m'endormir si je sais qu'une menace
imminente contrairement à Marie-Eve qui
me dit qu'elle avait réussi à s'endormir
je pense que le beaucoup plus
d'expérience que moi si vous voulez du
très concret il y a un aspect
d'imprévisibilité dans la guerre en
Ukraine
moi je trouve ça plus dangereux par
exemple aller en Afghanistan où on peut
se faire kidnapper où on peut se faire
assassiner alors que ça c'est pas un
souci en Ukraine qui nous suit au
quotidien quand on est dans une ville
relativement épargnée par les
bombardements c'est la vie est normale
on a aucun souci de sécurité on
s'habitue aux sirènes et on sait quoi
faire nous et je pense frédéric est ici
Frédéric Tremblay qui est un cameraman
qui a fait plusieurs voyages en Ukraine
aujourd'hui cette année on est allé à
Hakim quand ils ont commencé à libérer
la région et on est allé on dort loin de
la ligne de France et on a décidé de
dormir dans dans des petits chalets on
s'est dit c'est pas là qui vont attaquer
et finalement on a assisté le premier
missile qui a été lancé sur des
infrastructures électriques il y avait
une centrale électrique pas loin et en
plein souper le soir l'hôtel s'est mis à
trembler et
ça nous tombe dessus ça nous tombe
dessus c'est mais on a des équipes de ça
c'est le moi c'est les missiles que je
trouve les plus dangereux en ce moment
parce qu'on sait jamais exactement quand
ils vont tomber dans quelle région ils
vont tomber contrairement mais
tout s'est bien passé sauf que c'est sûr
que c'est pas toujours comme ça et on
essaie de l'éviter nos patrons nous
laissent pas aller là où c'est trop trop
dangereux on a eu plusieurs questions
qui se ressemblent Doris vaillant
Marie-Claude Aubin Patricia Hébert qui
veulent savoir une question très simple
est-ce que vous avez peur
[Rires]
ça m'arrive ben oui c'est sûr c'est sûr
je pense à mes enfants mais durant cette
attaque j'ai eu extrêmement peur j'étais
sous la table je me suis dit pourquoi je
suis ici ça nous passe par la tête je
sais pourquoi je vais en Ukraine c'est
un risque qu'on accepte mais qui est
tellement bas en tout cas quand à moi
est tellement calculé comme disait
Marie-Eve mais oui j'ai des moments de
peur
mais on est tellement bien entouré puis
je pense c'est important aussi vous
sachiez que on ne va pas on nous oblige
pas y aller on est une équipe et avant
chaque déplacement qui est moindrement
risqué il y a un consensus dans l'équipe
parce que tout le monde est à l'aise il
y a une préparation aussi voici ce qui
pourrait arriver voici ce qu'on fait si
ça arrive et même plus on s'approche du
danger on en reparle encore en tout cas
dans mon équipe à moi c'était comme ça
c'est rassurant c'est sûr que ça
n'empêche pas le pire d'arriver si ça
doit arriver
on calcule tout question par courriel de
Manon pépin de Boucherville
je pensais que vous aviez
j'aime pas beaucoup cette question là
parce que j'ai l'impression que j'ai
jamais de bonne réponse puis elle est
souvent incomprise par plusieurs parfois
même maisons je ne sais pas que je suis
immunisée je ressens de la peur dans la
vie mais quand je fais mon travail dans
ces milieux là pas vraiment j'ai
beaucoup plus d'appréhension parce que
j'ai toujours l'impression que les
choses auront bougé et c'est vrai ça
change souvent mais c'est des
appréhensions qui sont plus logistiques
mais ma plus grande part moi quand je
suis sur des terrains comme ça qui sont
un peu plus compliqués c'est de ne pas
être au bon endroit au bon moment et de
pas arriver à faire mon travail c'est ça
qui me préoccupe pour le reste c'est sûr
que je garde les mêmes réflexes que tout
le monde qui sont des réflexes de survie
s'il devait se produire quelque chose
j'imagine que je vais bouger mais je
reste toujours très calme c'est
je reviens à la question de Manon pépin
qui elle dit je m'interroge sur la
difficulté que les correspondants
doivent éprouver lorsque vient le temps
d'interviewer d'interviewer des
habitants de pays qui ne s'expriment pas
dans notre langue est-il difficile de
trouver des interprètes dans les pays où
les correspondants se rendent je pense à
vous Raphaël vous avez fait beaucoup de
pays limitrophes à l'Ukraine il y avait
beaucoup de réfugiés est-ce que c'est
compliqué d'entrer en contact avec la
population Marie-Eve est Amara parlait
de l'importance d'être au bon endroit au
bon moment il y a aussi l'autre scénario
qui celui quand est un petit peu en
retard c'est à dire que quand la guerre
a été déclenchée et c'est pas voulu
quand la guerre était déclenchée nous on
était à Paris on suivait davantage les
tractations diplomatiques parce qu'il y
en a eu beaucoup en Europe entre autres
puis quand la guerre a été déclenchée on
s'est dit il va il va y avoir
nécessairement
réfugiés qui vont venir dans les pays
limitrophes il faut y aller et là il
faut savoir agir rapidement et je
remercie ma collègue rechercher au
bureau de Paris Gabriel de jaser qui a
pris le téléphone moi aussi puis on
s'est mis à contacter ce qu'on appelle
donc il fait des on a parlé tout à
l'heure des fixer des gens qui sont sur
place et qui peuvent nous aider à
justement parler aux gens et là quand la
guerre était déclenchée vous comprenez
que tous les grands réseaux du monde ont
décidé de se rendre en Pologne pour
justement parler de cette arrivée des
réfugiés c'était pas évident on a fini
par trouver une fiction qui a fait un
travail extraordinaire qui n'était pas
une ancienne journaliste qui était une
fille qui travaillait en marketing et
qui s'est rendu disponible pour nous
puis il y avait un degré supplémentaire
également en Pologne au début de la gare
c'est que les gens qui nous aident sont
polonais mais les gens qui arrivent qui
fuient la guerre ne parlent pas
nécessairement le polonais il parle
ukrainien et là faut trouver des moyens
de trouver quelqu'un qui parle ukrainien
pour pouvoir traduire donc un certain
degré de difficultés on y arrive parfois
on tombe sur des gens qui par l'Anglais
aussi de plus en plus toujours le cas
mais seul l'île quand même à l'occasion
parfois même des gens qui parlent
français c'est entre beaucoup de cas en
Roumanie en Moldavie en Italie où il y a
une grande culture francophone encore
mais donc oui il faut savoir chaque fois
trouver des gens qui peuvent nous aider
sur le terrain à faire notre travail ça
c'est un des défis parce que quand je
parlais d'arrivée un petit peu plus tard
trouver la voiture de location trouver
des chambres d'hôtel quand tous les
médias du monde c'est pas évident on
arrive à le faire parfois on partage la
chambre avec le cameraman il y a toutes
sortes de scénarios possibles mais on
fait ce qu'il faut pour être là quand on
a un tout petit peu de droite j'avoue
était impressionné et lorsque j'écoute
vos reportages assis sur mon divan avec
ma conjointe on est toujours
impressionné de voir à quel point vous
réussissez à trouver des gens qui
parlent français un peu partout dans le
monde que ce soit c'est pas notre
critère aux États-Unis en Europe partout
c'est quand même fascinant vous promenez
avec un écriteau ici parlez-vous
français comment vous faites pour les
trouver Frédéric vous en avez souvent
dans vos reportages j'essaie d'en avoir
c'est sûr que pour moi c'est pas
forcément un critères pour couvrir
quelque chose c'est sûr que
des gens qui nous écoutent qui nous
regardent bon ils vont être plus
sensibilisés peut-être et plus
intéressés parce que à la personne parle
français sauf que parfois dans le cas
des États-Unis ceux qui parlent français
des Américains qui ont pris le français
d'abord c'est ils viennent d'un certain
une certaine partie de la société
souvent ils sont plus ouverts sur le
monde donc on va dire par ricochets qui
sont aussi plus démocrates donc on va en
trouver moins souvent du côté
républicain donc il y a ce côté là c'est
un plus pour nous c'est sûr pour les
gens qui écoutent les reportages et puis
les regardent mais c'est il faut il faut
essayer de refléter l'ensemble de la
diversité de la population américaine et
oui en français c'est bien mais des fois
on risque de manquer peut-être un petit
morceau de l'histoire si on focalise nos
efforts juste pour avoir des parles en
français comment puis on on doit pas
avoir tout le crédit des fois c'est le
pur fruit du hasard ce sont des gens qui
nous entendent parler français avec
notre équipe qui viennent nous voir on
commence à discuter avec nous une super
conversation puis là-dessus franchement
c'est le hasard qui fait bien les choses
on retourne dans la salle la Nick Béraud
a une question
les gens veulent beaucoup savoir ce que
vous ressentez sur le terrain et je me
dirige vers Béatrice Mathieu étudiante
si vous voulez vous lever vous aussi
pour vous dire votre question vos
correspondants merci oui je me demandais
quand vous étiez à l'étranger est-ce
qu'il y a eu une rencontre qui vous a
marqué plus qu'une autre
goût de répondre à celle-là j'imagine
qu'il y en a beaucoup qui vous vient en
tête AZ Philippe je sais pas
moi il y a une rencontre il y a le
docteur ben il y en a beaucoup en fait
il y a le docteur mukwe que j'avais
rencontré à Winnipeg qui est un
gynécologue qui
fait beaucoup d'opérations chez les
femmes parce qu'au Congo le corps de la
femme est devenu un peu un champ de
bataille à cause des viols et c'est
devenu une arme de guerre donc c'est un
homme qui a vraiment voué sa vie à
sauver ces femmes là et ça c'était
c'était une rencontre qui m'a beaucoup
marqué parce que ce sont des gens qui
travaillent un peu dans l'ombre aussi
qui sont pas souvent devant les caméras
et qui travaillent d'arrache-pied pour
changer les choses donc ça c'est une
rencontre qui m'avait marqué il était
venu à Winnipeg il était avec Roméo
Dallaire d'ailleurs qui se battait aussi
pour pour ces femmes là et il était
escorté par la GRC l'été escorté par des
policiers parce que c'est un homme qui
risquait sa vie en faisant ça parce que
même
même essayer de guérir des femmes
c'était
lutter contre ce que beaucoup voulaient
nous avaient expliqué que ces femmes là
étaient victimes parce qu'elle vivait à
côté de mines et que c'était une façon
de de décourager les populations locales
en violence et femme là donc ça c'était
une rencontre qui m'avait beaucoup
marquée mais aussi aussi la résilience
des gens vous savez quand on est aux
États-Unis par exemple quand on que ce
soit quand on couvre les manifestations
pour le droit à l'avortement toutes ces
femmes qui se battent pour faire
respecter ce droit là qui essaie de
soutenir des jeunes femmes qui essaient
de se faire avorter qui veulent
conserver ce droit là c'est aussi c'est
c'est important des gens qui se battent
dans l'ombre au Kentucky où il y a une
tornade et avoir une dame qui va
commencer à distribuer à manger aux gens
pour les aider parce qu'ils se
retrouvent sans maison donc il y a
beaucoup d'héros qui font pas
nécessairement la une des médias mais
qui sont très impressionnants et qui
font qui font beaucoup d'héroïsme
finalement j'ai une question de Michel
ruelle de Sainte-Agathe-des-Monts qui se
demandent on entend régulièrement les
commentaires sur la propagande russe en
regard de la guerre en Ukraine les
Ukrainiens doivent bien faire eux aussi
une certaine forme de propagande est-ce
que vous le voyez sur le terrain il
l'entendez-vous comme journaliste
comment vous pouvez faire vraiment la
part des choses et être objectif sur ce
plan Philippe vous avez passé beaucoup
de temps en Ukraine à vivre notamment
est-ce que à un moment donné on en vient
qu'à perdre un petit peu le la distance
absolument et c'est pour ça que quand
j'y étais d'ailleurs on a établi un
centre de presse ou on voulait aider les
gens à y voir plus clair parce qu'on
était conscient c'était au tout début de
la guerre en Ukraine on était conscient
de cette désinformation là de la
propagande russe mais on commençait à
prendre connaissance de la propagande
ukrainienne et peut-être qu'au début on
n'a pas été aussi au fait de se
propagande là probablement que Mario oui
parce qu'elle avait l'expérience mais il
y avait beaucoup de journalistes qui
prenaient tout ce qu'on nous disait tout
ce qui provenait des sources officielles
ukrainiennes comme étant des faits donc
et bien un moment donné où il y a
automatiquement dans notre cerveau un
doute qui s'installe quand on parle aux
gens quand on nous dit quelque chose
j'ai vu ça ou mon mon collègue est allé
voir à tel endroit il y avait trois
quatre morts qui étaient affalé là alors
que personne d'autre en parle donc on se
met à douter puis là c'est là que le
journaliste en nous doit vraiment
pousser plus loin même si naturellement
ben moi j'étais du côté élevé où on
recevait les réfugiés où on était dans
l'entraide ou tu sais c'était plus
une B2 entre guillemets avec la
population
ukrainienne donc faut être très très
prudent dans ce moment-là
mensonge mais il y a quand même un
effort de communication de vouloir
mettre la lumière sur certains faits
peut-être parfois trop
et ça on le vit beaucoup avec toutes les
armées que l'on côtoie l'armée
ukrainienne est une armée qui contrôle
énormément le message et l'image et
parfois
façon de déjouer ça c'est de se rendre
et d'aller voir les choses de nos
propres yeux et ça c'est je pense que
c'est une frustration que toutes les
équipes qui ont couvert la guerre du
côté ukrainien ont vécu on partageait
qu'il soit ukrainien ou étrangers
d'ailleurs c'est cette tentative de
contrôle c'est à dire attendez les lieux
ne sont pas prêts vous ne pouvez pas
entrer dans cette ville et les libérer
mais on a l'impression parfois que c'est
pour leur permettre de faire une mise en
scène pour guider notre regard pour nous
dire qui on doit parler de ces choses là
je racontais une anecdote mais ce qu'on
a vu à bout de chat par exemple quand
dans les toutes premières heures de la
libération de bucial à banlieue de Kiev
on a vu ses corps qu'ils ont fait la rue
avec les chars russes brûlées ça c'est
une information qui est à vif qui n'a
pas été contrôlée c'est ce qu'on
découvre dans les premiers instants mais
il faut y être à ce moment-là et je
pense que c'est assez clair qu'il y a
des crimes de guerre qui ont été commis
après il faut faire en quête pour voir
dans quelles circonstances et tout ça
c'est dans les tous premiers instants
mais par la suite même à bout de chat ou
l'horreur était évidente et qui était
nécessaire d'en ajouter j'ai vécu moi un
moment où on était on accompagnait
l'armée ukrainienne qui allait un peu
plus loin dans la ville et ils avaient
découvert des études des corps ils
étaient si score complètement calcinés
mais quand on est arrivé sur la scène on
était plusieurs journalistes étrangers
plusieurs qui avaient beaucoup
d'expérience de nombreux scènes
d'horreur et on a tous eu un réflexe de
recul en se disant
ça nous semble une mise en scène pas que
les corps ont pas été calcinés pour
qu'ils ont pas été découvert mais la
façon dont ils étaient posés qu'on avait
les médecins légistes qui travaillaient
autour moi j'avais l'impression qu'on me
présentait un truc qui avait déjà été
mâché sans me donner l'opportunité de
vérifier quoi que ce soit parce qu'il y
avait plus de gens interviewés alors je
dis pas que les Ukrainiens me mentait
nécessairement mais très certainement
ils arrangé un peu cette image enfin moi
j'étais pas à l'aise donc on a décidé
cette journée-là de tout simplement de
pas utiliser le matériel si je peux pas
le vérifier aussi horrible ce soir il y
a probablement une bonne part de vérité
dans ce que dans ce que les Ukrainiens
ont présenté il faut faire des choix
comme ça aussi c'est qu'un contrôle de
l'information autant du côté russe que
du côté ukrainien et ça c'est important
que vous sachez que ça nous ça nous est
imposé et quand ils nous accueille en
Ukraine c'est vrai que c'est abraz
ouvert parce qu'ils veulent des médias
étrangers mais ça vient avec une carte
de presse et certaines conditions on
peut pas on n'est pas complètement libre
d'aller tourner nous on a été arrêté
avec Frédéric par des policiers à la
sortie d'un hôpital ils nous ont retenu
pendant une heure il voulait qu'on les
vos images ça c'est l'armée ukrainienne
et les autorités ukrainiennes donc il y
a
[Musique]
un souci mais c'est plus un souci c'est
une obsession aussi du contrôle du
message qui s'applique des deux côtés
question de Michael Sévigny de Montréal
qui peut s'appliquer au conflit en
Ukraine mais qui peut s'appliquer à
plusieurs de vos déploiements à
l'étranger comment fait-on comme
correspondant pour protéger sa santé
mentale lorsqu'on couvre des conflits
que ce soit en Ukraine ou ailleurs et
qu'on était moins de scènes déchirantes
jour après jour
qui veut répondre à son premier
c'est sûr que quand on part que ce soit
en Ukraine ou n'importe où en général
c'est rarement pour aller faire quelque
chose hop la vie donc et on ne sait
jamais quand est-ce qu'on va revenir non
plus donc ça veut dire que à un moment
donné ça commence à à peser un peu sur
le mental parce que c'est jamais très
très positif et puis surtout il y a
énormément de pression aussi pour livrer
les reportages en parfois on travaille
on peut travailler des journées de 15-18
20h parfois parfois on ne dort pas du
tout donc je pense c'est important
malgré tout d'arriver à faire une à
faire une pause changer les idées juste
c'est juste par exemple essayer de
trouver un endroit où on pourrait
s'asseoir manger juste comme on essaie
de avec le caméraman la technicien ou en
conséquence sécurité que on prenne le
temps de et on a travaillé fort aussi
c'est et de se changer des idées de
parler d'autre chose aussi de parler
d'autre chose et puis quand on revient
de couverture ben c'est de retrouver un
peu notre cocon familial de de prendre
le temps de cuisiner de enfin moi j'aime
bien la cuisine ça me permet de m'évader
un peu de faire une paella ou bien de
faire une cuisson sous vide l'appui de
partager ça avec des amis et de parler
d'autre chose et de sortir un peu de ce
cette espèce de chape de plan parfois
qui parce qu'on revient avec ça avec
nous c'est pas parce qu'on quitte un
endroit que ah ça y est c'est parti non
ça ça nous construit aussi ça nous donne
une armure aussi pour essayer de
continuer parce qu'on fait un travail
quand même qui qui nous amène à côtoyer
de la misère et de la souffrance et on
est témoin de ça et donc on essaye de se
donner un peu d'oxygène dans le cerveau
dans le cœur et c'est pour ça que la
famille les ancrages tout ça c'est
important de se replonger là-dedans
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il y a un
sentiment d'impuissance en fait moi
quand j'ai couvert le tremblement de
terre en Haïti on est arrivé là puis
c'est on arrive parfois souvent avant
les premières répondants et de voir les
gens quand même arrivent à s'organiser
nous bon on a il y a eu des répliques
aussi donc on dormait dans des tentes
mais ce qui nous ce qui nous aide
énormément c'est nos collègues moi j'ai
mon collègue cameraman Sylvain Silva
Richard et puis on en parle on discute
et le fait de faire le reportage c'est
assez thérapeutique mais aussi quand on
parle aux gens en fait on se rend compte
que pour eux ben c'est un quotidien que
nous on pense pas du tout à notre petite
personne parce que eux c'est ils vivent
avec ça il va peut-être y avoir d'autres
répliques ou encore quand on était allé
voir les migrants dans le sud des
États-Unis à la frontière du Texas par
exemple vous voyez des gens qui ont
marché des mois et des mois dire nous on
est quand même extrêmement privilégié là
on va on va prendre un bout de leur vie
avec notre micro et il nous raconte
leurs histoires on revient chez nous moi
je pense pas à ma personne comment je me
sens etc pas du tout je pense plutôt à
eux qui qui vont être on les a pas
vraiment aidés comment ils vont s'en
sortir qu'est-ce qui va arriver donc je
pense que on est quand même dans un dans
une position extrêmement privilégiée on
pense pas vraiment à notre santé mentale
enfin moi pas du tout je vous rappelle
qu'on est dans le cadre de la Semaine
des correspondants de Radio-Canada on
vous présente aujourd'hui une édition
spéciale de midi info en direct de
l'Atrium de la nouvelle Maison de
Radio-Canada Montréal la mission est
aussi diffusée sur Radio-Canada.ca sur
Youtube et sur la page Facebook de
Radio-Canada info on va mettre un peu de
côté la guerre en Ukraine parce que oui
elle a pris beaucoup de place cette
année mais vous avez aussi couvert de
nombreux autres sujets des libertés
brimées un peu partout dans le monde on
a qu'à penser aux femmes en Iran
l'Afghanistan aussi même aux femmes
américaines qui ont vu leur droit à
l'avortement être mis en question par la
Cour suprême américaine au mois de juin
dernier beaucoup de réfugiés de migrants
aussi un peu partout dans le monde la
censure en Chine en Russie et beaucoup
de colère beaucoup de colère de
soulèvement de manifestations vous en
avez couvert beaucoup aussi Raphaël
Bouvier au clair vous êtes en Europe
vous avez été notamment en
Grande-Bretagne où il y a une très forte
colère beaucoup de grève du secteur
public mais en France aussi ça brosse
quand même beaucoup vous avez été en
poste à Washington quand Donald Trump
était au pouvoir c'est aussi très
polarisant est-ce que c'est plus
difficile de faire son travail de
journaliste de correspondance sur le
terrain avec cette polarisation cette
vague de colère qu'on sent un peu
partout mais c'est clair que dans
certains contextes on parlait des
rassemblements de Donald Trump mais
c'était ça peut être le cas dans des
rassemblements du dirigeant hongrois
Victor urbanne aussi il y a une certaine
haine à l'endroit des médias c'est clair
on en parle on le voit puis nos
collègues qui sont basés ici au Canada
peuvent le constater en être témoin dans
certains contextes évidemment donc on
peut pas dire que ça facilite le travail
ce qui peut jouer en notre faveur
parfois et ça je l'ai constaté entre
autres aux États-Unis particulièrement
la radio parce que quand on se déploie à
la télé qu'on a une caméra ça attire
l'attention de manière différente à la
radio il y a une discrétion qui joue
beaucoup en notre faveur mais c'est de
représenter un média étranger
représenter un média canadien un pays
qui est encore peut-être pas en Russie
Tamara mais toujours la cote dans
plusieurs pays et comme il y a une haine
qui est dirigeait beaucoup à l'endroit
des médias nationaux je pense au grand
média américain je pense à certains
réseaux de nouvelles en continu en
France ben nous en étant étranger
pendant ce pas de recul là il y a des
gens qui même s'ils sont hostiles aux
médias acceptent de se raconter de se
livrer à nous de nous dire pourquoi ils
vivent ces frustrations là et ça ça aide
beaucoup notre travail je pense le fait
d'être représentant d'un média étranger
c'est pas toujours le cas évidemment
cette haine à l'endroit des médias on la
sent peu importe le contexte peu importe
le pays dans lequel on se trouve mais il
y a quand même ce petit côté là qui fait
en sorte qu'on peut peut-être un peu
plus facilement faire notre travail que
nos collègues par exemple français ou
encore surtout américaine question
d'Annick Bero en fait pas de vous Annick
mais du public allez-y oui il y a
beaucoup de questions sur la latitude
que vous avez dans votre travail si
entre autres je crois le sens de votre
question madame Thérèse Nadeau c'est à
vous oui j'aimerais savoir si vous avez
quatre blanches dans vos choix ou si
vous avez des contraintes
en arrière de tout ça là
le choix des sujets cartes blanches oui
non qui a envie de répondre à cette
question c'est pas qu'on a carte blanche
mais on nous donne on nous accorde
beaucoup de confiance dans le cas de la
Russie par exemple si moi la seule qui
est là canadienne et dans le petit
biscuit on était le seul média canadien
donc on est les mieux placés pour donner
une direction à la couverture c'est sûr
que on doit consulter Patrick notre
affectateur qui consulte ensuite une
équipe
de la direction si c'est des
déplacements plus compliqués mais moi
j'ai senti pendant quatre ans que oui
j'avais carte blanche parce que c'est ça
la beauté d'être correspondante c'est
qu'on n'arrive pas et on je pense que
ceci serait intéressant et j'ai une
semaine pour le faire c'est qu'on habite
on baigne dans cette culture là on peut
se déplacer donc
pas blanc blanc mais carte blanche quand
même moi ce que je vois en Asie c'est
que il y a l'aspect carte blanche au
niveau éditorial mais j'ai l'autre
aspect qui est pas j'ai pas carte
blanche en termes de pouvoir réaliser
tout ce que je voudrais faire parce que
dans l'ensemble des pays à peu près
partout en Asie il y a des restrictions
importantes à la liberté de presse et
c'est de plus en plus partout sur la
planète qu'on voit ça c'est un endroit
qui nous semble presque paradisiaque
mais j'étais à Singapour par exemple en
2021 il y a un contrôle important de
l'information je me faisais quand même
suivre certains moments par le
gouvernement comme Annick le vécu en
Chine et ça demeure une réalité on veut
faire certains sujets on pense qu'on est
capable mais c'est pas toujours
nécessairement faisable sur le terrain
je pense que pour je pense on a carte
blanche je pense qu'il faut le dire
comme télévision d'État radio d'état
aussi on travaille pas pour une
entreprise privée ça c'est extrêmement
important important donc on a une
liberté de choix des sujets la façon
dont on fait nos reportages évidemment
on a un code d'éthique on a les normes
de pratique journalistique à
Radio-Canada pour que nos reportages
soient équilibré mais je pense moi je me
retrouve souvent sur le terrain avec des
télévisions que ce soit Fox ou CNN ou il
y a une tendance alors que nous on reste
quand même assez
assez neutre si vous voulez dans notre
dans notre couverture donc on a cette
carte blanche là mais pour pour avoir
commencé ce métier il y a très longtemps
j'avoue que sur le terrain il y a une
radicalisation avant la presse était
perçue comme on nous accueillait on
était vraiment ce cinquième pouvoir on
était alors que maintenant on devient un
peu une cible c'est un peu ce que vous
êtes fake news on nous pose souvent
cette question là Frédéric et moi quand
on est aux États-Unis nous on leur dit
bon on est canadien bon ça ça passe mais
il y a on remet en question ce qu'on dit
l'effet l'effet journalistique on
parlait des faits alternatifs aux
États-Unis donc il y a une méfiance
énormément des médias qu'il n'y avait
pas dans le passé
question de Julie Cavanna par courriel
le soulèvement des femmes iraniennes est
la première révolution féministe de
l'histoire pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas de
correspondants pour couvrir la situation
en Iran Marie-Ève vous êtes rendu au
Kurdistan irakien pour parler à des
stands dernier je pense pour parler des
iraniennes là-bas pourquoi on est pas
allé en Iran tout simplement parce qu'on
n'y a pas accès on n'a pas de visa on
est en demande de visa pour l'Iran de
façon quasibe enfin moi de quelle façon
quasi permanente dans la vie c'est un
document qu'on renouvelle on rappelle
une demande de visa on va prendre le thé
mais c'est très difficile d'y accéder
souvent il y a pas
on nous on nous ouvre les portes il y a
des élections parce que on veut montrer
que les gens votent mais la
principalement dans une période
difficile où il y a des manifestations
où il y a une contestation du régime au
pouvoir une répression qui est
excessivement violente de cette
contestation là et personne du régime
iranien qui veut voir les médias
étrangers débarqués au pays et c'est une
source pour nous de frustration énorme
parce qu'on voudrait rendre compte de ça
il y a un mouvement qui historique et
qui est très courageux de la part de ces
femmes là donc le mieux qu'on a pu faire
oui pour les rencontrer et se rapprocher
un peu de cette histoire là c'est
d'aller au Kurdistan irakien parce que
certaines femmes sortaient des femmes
d'origine kurde aussi des iraniennes qui
sortaient illégalement elles étaient
trafiquées par des bandits à la
frontière pour pouvoir aller rejoindre
des groupes
iraniens Kurdes qui sont installés du
côté de l'Irak et qui ont rejoint dans
des milices armées parce qu'elles nous
ont dit elles sont pas hyper nombreuses
ça reste une route assez périlleuse et
compliquée mais ce qui nous disait
surtout je pense le message c'est on
veut y retourner mais mieux préparer
mieux armés parce que on fait pas le
poids
un sujet qu'on ne pensait peut-être pas
couvrir en 2022 c'est le droit à
l'avortement aux États-Unis coût de
tonnerre la Cour suprême mange un
dernier à Z ben vous avez beaucoup
couvert ce sujet là est-ce que vous avez
été étonné qu'on en soit là en 2022 les
Américains l'ont beaucoup été
c'est-à-dire c'était beaucoup nous
disaient on retourne 50 ans en arrière
arriver à des cliniques d'avortement de
voir des jeunes femmes escortées par des
étudiants des bénévoles c'est on parlait
à des femmes qui s'étaient qui avait
manifesté pendant des années pour ce
droit à l'avortement et de voir que tout
est remis en question et puis là
aujourd'hui alors on se parle au congrès
à la Chambre des Représentants ils sont
en train de restreindre aussi l'accès à
l'avortement ça va certainement pas
passer au Sénat mais quand même c'est
des acquis qui sont remis en question à
cause un peu de la Cour suprême on
assiste juges conservateurs qui ont été
nommés par les républicains dont trois
par dans notre chambre et trois
démocrates donc les juges à la Cour
suprême il y a pas vraiment un équilibre
si vous voulez donc beaucoup d'acquis
sont retirés et ça c'est sûr que c'est
c'est quelque chose que beaucoup de
femmes aux États-Unis on pensait pas que
ça ça pouvait arriver ici on prend ça
pour acquis c'est le droit au choix en
fait et il y a beaucoup de femmes en
fait qui sont qui sont Provis qui sont
contre l'avortement qui s'il y a
beaucoup la religion aussi là-dedans et
c'est c'est un peu un retour en arrière
sur beaucoup d'aspects
qui nous écoute en web diffusion qui
pose une question est-ce que vous avez
parfois l'impression que vous reportages
peuvent influencer les autorités locales
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'en
posant des questions par exemple un
ministre Premier ministre à l'étranger
ou alors que vous pose des questions
dans la rue que les autorités locales
vous écoutent et que ça peut influencer
la manière dont il
dirige le pays je vois Raphaël vous en
avez fait plusieurs des je pense qu'ils
regardent plusieurs ou écoute plusieurs
autres médias avant nous avant nous
mais je pense que je voulais déjà
raconté ça Alec quand la réussite a
développé le premier vaccin le Spoutnik
alors on était très fière elle sauter
les étapes scientifiques on s'entend
avant de le commercialiser en Russie et
j'ai fait un reportage quand le 27 une
revue médicale très prestigieuse lui a
donné la cote en disant oui c'est un bon
vaccin il a été fait
pas comme on l'aurait fait nous mais
c'est un bon vaccin et moi j'ai fait un
reportage là dessus avec des faits et je
me suis retrouvé à la Une de plusieurs
médias russe
félicite il se gêne pas pour nous ça
c'est à l'époque avant l'expulsion mais
c'est c'est oui mais ça vous dit ça vous
dit qu'on était écouté et cela dit ce
qui peut se produire par contre c'est le
phénomène inverse parfois on va faire
des reportages sur des sujets d'affaires
publics des sujets liés à l'urbanisme et
ça peut susciter une conversation ici au
Canada et quand ça se produit on se dit
notre travail aura servi à quelque chose
aura contribué à la conversation par
exemple quand on compare les systèmes de
sens de santé ou d'autres thèmes du
genre là ça peut avoir un impact ici
là-bas dans notre cas en France par
exemple je ne pense pas que que l'Elysée
non Macron
rdiment en permanence malheureusement
Marie-Eve vous nous avez présenté un
reportage une série de reportages sur la
situation des femmes et des fillettes en
Afghanistan vous avez entre autres
rencontré des familles là où les parents
vendent carrément leur fille parfois là
dès l'âge de 8 ans pour leur permettre
de subsister on a reçu une question par
courriel de Louis-Philippe Pelletier qui
demande diriez-vous que c'est un aspect
difficile de votre travail que de ne pas
pouvoir soulager davantage la misère que
vous rencontrez vous arrive-t-il de
donner un coup de main lorsque les
caméras sont fermées pour aider ceux à
qui vous parlez
est-ce que c'est oui c'est un aspect qui
est difficile de travail mais je pense
qu'on a tous ce même sentiment à Z tout
à l'heure parler d'impuissance quand on
est amené à travailler sur des terrains
comme ceux-là particulièrement en
Afghanistan ou on voit la situation
dégradée à une vitesse
grand V c'est c'est dur de laisser tout
ça derrière nous sans pouvoir agir
est-ce que ça nous arrive d'aider on est
humain je pense qu'on fait tous preuves
à un moment ou à un autre de générosité
sans que ça devienne
un échange ou une pression pour que ces
gens-là nous parlent
parce que ça c'est toujours très délicat
aussi et puis surtout si on fait face à
des gens qui sont dans une pauvreté
extrême il faut s'assurer que ces
gens-là ne nous parlent pas dans
l'espoir qu'au moins de même puisse
manger
ça j'ai pas laissé c'est toujours très
complexe parce qu'on parle pas
nécessairement leur langue les
conversations sont pas direct et puis je
vous dis pas qu'on y arrive toujours
mais c'est c'est les je pense que c'est
le défi auquel on fait face constamment
parce que cette personne là accepte
d'ouvrir la porte dans ce cas-ci c'était
des tentes alors de nous permettre de
s'asseoir sous la tente et regarder
mettre les projecteurs sur la misère
dans laquelle on est pour que ça nous
rapporte quelque chose
ils étaient tous très volontaires les
gens de nous parler et ne s'en cachait
pas beaucoup mais parce que c'était je
pense que c'était une façon interposée
aussi pour eux d'être entendu parce
qu'il y a plus personne qui les écoutait
en Afghanistan à leur avis depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir des talibans il y a
énormément de restriction il y a la
disparition des droits des femmes les
droits humains c'est une catastrophe
mais il y a aussi tous les programmes
d'aide qui étaient soit internationaux
mais aussi du gouvernement qui
disparaisse ces gens-là ne reçoivent
plus rien parce qu'ils ne comptent pas
pour le pouvoir c'est ce qui nous disent
je pense que pour eux c'est une façon de
de maintenir une voix après
est-ce que il y a des sacs de riz du
lait du sucre des choses qui peuvent
être dirigés vers ces gens-là quand ils
ne reçoivent chez eux bien sûr mais ça
je pense que c'est une courtoisie on se
présente chez personne les mains vides
généralement quand on nous ouvre la
porte mamie si vous m'invitez à manger
je vous promets j'apporte au moins le
vin c'est c'est
jamais que ça soit une condition ou un
sous-entendu à nous recevoir qu'on va
les aider parce que
c'est vivable comme situation mais oui
on est humain et puis nous c'est une
tradition il y a des pays ici si on va
faire une entrevue chez des gens à ma
connaissance on n'aurait jamais rien
amené avec nous en Russie c'est c'est
peut-être moi personnellement mais en
Russie quand on va chez des gens qui ont
6 sont dans le besoin avant de partir on
l'avait dans le coffre on aurait été à
l'épicerie on a acheté de la farine de
l'eau des biscuits des c'est jamais un
échange c'est ça qui est important de
savoir et quand on peut aider sans que
ça devienne la norme le problème c'est
que dans les situations très chaotiques
si on est d'une personne ça peut créer
des émeutes on nous a toujours dit ça
fait partie aussi de nos formations
aussi par exemple en Haïti quand il
distribuait pendant le tremblement de
terre moi j'étais pas là mais je sais
que tu veux donner oui te débarque
tendres nous on a toujours des bartendes
tu veux les donner aux enfants qui
crèvent de faim mais c'est endonneurs
on l'avait fait nous moi j'étais là
aussi comme azaba après le tremblement
de terre puis un autre moment donné un
ouragan en Haïti puis un moment donné on
s'est dit on va aller à un coin de rue
très tranquille on a bu deux trois
enfants qui avaient absolument rien on a
dit nous il nous reste un peu de
nourriture des bouteilles d'eau surtout
on repart demain on va leur donner et
dès qu'on s'est mis à repartir on a vu
une meute qui s'est ruée vers ses
enfants là et la crainte c'est qu'on
crée davantage d'injustice parmi ces
gens question du public oui vous êtes
nos vieux et il nous oreilles sur dans
des dizaines de pays à travers la
planète et ça c'est interpelle beaucoup
les gens ça ressort beaucoup dans les
questions et je crois que c'est le sens
de votre question monsieur Jocelyn a
gagné
principalement adressé à Philippe moi
j'ai de la difficulté à comprendre
comment vous pouvez faire votre travail
et puis même aussi la direction de
Radio-Canada de d'avoir un pays
incontinent cliquez l'Asie qui est plus
que 50% de la population mondiale
et que vous êtes une personne un homme
orchestre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]